there was the queue
and now there's the cube before the
queue
and not the warmest of welcomes for
those joining it
but thousands like alastair are
undeterred by the weight or the walk
her majesty gave us 70 years what's
giving her of nine hours that's nothing
despite being five miles from
westminster turning back was never an
option for alison from richmond in
yorkshire who's honoring a promise to
her late mum
i'd work 21 hours for her
when i was very little me and my mom
said we would come to this my mom's
passed away
so i'm here for her and nanny aren't we
yeah
many are making this pilgrimage for
their loved ones and when that
opportunity looks like it's slipping
away frustration comes to the fall
sit on the line
they should have known
[Music]
snaking through southwark park is taking
on average three hours every so often
pressure is relieved on the pens and the
queue surges forward by another hundred
meters it is
overwhelming when you first enter but
morale is high people expected it
and so they marched on among them
football legend david beckham have you
been waiting long david folks a little
while
who like so many in those precious
seconds was overcome
i think it's emotional for um
for everybody involved you know to
obviously um
i think to be here to to
you know to celebrate the way we we have
done with everybody today i think it's
been a
it's been a special day
but it's not without its challenges
by night safety in the queue becomes
more demanding dozens have been taken to
hospital after fainting and there's been
a sexual assault charge for someone
waiting in line
as temperatures dip the resilience of
thousands is tested as they now face a
24-hour wait
ash naharinag sky news in southeast
london